mio padre amava le donne tutte
indistintamente diceva che le donne sono
farfalle in testa posseggono la
polverina che le fa volare ma se un uomo
gliela ruba rimangono a terra di vengono
con cile papa anche la mamma è una
farfalla no tua madre è sempre stata una
rana l'aveva conosciuta quando ancora
una parte della terra di proprietà del
nostro padrone non era stata bonificata
c'erano nuvole di zanzare e grossetane
che si gonfiavano come mongolfiere le
rane non cantano sono monotone le rane e
ripetitive proprio come mia madre
conosceva infatti solo poche parole e il
suo corpo aveva la grazia dell'acqua
stagnante che non si muove in numerosi
party l'avevano lasciato la pancia
rigonfia e le gambe leggermente
divaricate all'infuori la sua pelle era
stata sempre opaca non fu mai un amante
per mio padre ma solo una madre e
compagna non ricordo tra loro gesti
d'affetto so però che lui l'amava e
l'adorava e la rispettava come la
madonna
lo so perché non l'ha mai picchiata
anche quando tornava ubriaco
dall'osteria eccitato con due gote rosse
sulla faccia e le goccioline di sudore
che brillavano sul collo per i giochi
fantasiosi delle sue amiche non c'era un
dialogo tra mio padre e mia madre non
era necessario erano abituati al
silenzio e ai vuoti non solo di parole è
una brava donna tua madre e se la
povertà non le avesse rubato il
desiderio e il pensiero sarebbe stata
una moglie ideale ma mia madre mio padre
era diversa da lui era devota solo al
dovere per lei la vita era sacrificio
non provava gioia nel vivere ma
rassegnazione ma credo che proprio lei
pensava a mio padre
ogni volta che raccontava la storia di
una donna pensava a lei alla sua
sottomissione alla sua incapacità di
sognare ma pensava a lei le donne della
mia terra
profumano come le rose di san giovanni e
sembrano anfore con i pugni poggiati
sopra i fianchi custodi di liquidi
ancestrali il loro ritmo è quello lunare
sacerdotesse di credi antichi dove i
figli sono l'unica ricchezza i vecchi
rappresentano la saggezza dei popoli
non si sa come facciano l'amore perché
non ostentano la sensualità nella danno
a vedere ma l'ondeggiare dei lunghi
capelli neri e il calpestio dei piedi
scalzi sul pavimento delle case
promettono melodie da sirene infatti
cantano mentre faccenda no cantano
sempre sono terra e mare
le mie donne sono le mie figlie
mia madre
la mia donna sono tutte le donne del sud
che ancora cantano e cantano e non si
stancheranno mai di cantare